how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about Marvel of course DC Star Wars and
other great things as well today we have
some major news in regards to Marvel's
phase four and phase five it has been
revealed that Marvel Studios has booked
2 hours and 45 minutes for a
presentation at this year's CinemaCon
now this is some pretty big news because
no matter what happens we're going to
get a lot from Marvel just in case some
of you do not know last year at
CinemaCon they showed a full scene from
Avengers in game they showed the scene
where nebula talks about Thanos and the
farm Captain Marvel says we're going to
go get this guy and then it showed them
flying off into space now they only
showed this to the people at CinemaCon
of course it wasn't released anywhere
else after but the people who watched it
wrote everything known and then put it
online for all of us to see so
essentially we figured out what the
opening scene of Avengers in game was
but this year Marvel has 2 hours and 45
minutes that is a ton of time so let's
talk about what we could possibly get
from Marvel Studios at CinemaCon if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel also I'm
giving away an Xbox one and the ps4 and
all you have to do is be subscribed with
notifications turned on like the video
and leave a comment below to enter so as
I mentioned 2 hours and 45 minutes is
just a ton of time for Marvel Studios to
have at CinemaCon the big question is
what are they going to be talking about
and what are they going to be showing
now one thing that we're going to get
from phase 4 that's pretty much 100%
confirmed is a new scene from Black
Widow this is pretty much a given it's
going to be the first movie of phase 4
coming out it's the next movie that
we're going to be seen in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and it's only just a
little bit over three months away now
there has been speculation that this
time could be reserved to show the black
widow film in its entirety
however this probably won't happen
simply due to the fact that whoever goes
and watches it will most likely leak it
online which means the entire public
will know exactly what happens in the
Black Widow movie and they're not going
to have the whole entire Black Widow
movie spoiled three months before it
comes out so we're most likely going to
get a clip from Black Widow but we're
also most likely going to get some type
of footage from the Eternals because
this has already happened at CC XP it is
possible that we could get shown the
trailer footage from the set of the
Eternals has been leaking left and
lately but we've seen everything rahhh
nothing has been edited yet so this is
something that will most likely see at
CinemaCon now even if Kevin Feige does
show and talk about these films for
maybe 30 minutes each that's still an
hour and 45 minutes left so there's a
very high possibility since Wan Division
and the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series are already in production and
filming that we could get some type of
footage from those two as well this is
probably the most likely scenario for
cinema con footage and some major
reveals probably of the black widow
movie the Eternals movie one division
series and Falcon and the Winter Soldier
series as well however even if Marvel
Studios takes two hours to show footage
and talk about each of these projects
that still leaves 45 minutes still a ton
of time to talk about things and a
perfect time to reveal new projects now
they've already revealed all of phase 4
and unless they've added anything to
phase 4 which is unlikely because it's
already jam-packed the next couple of
years the only thing left to reveal is
phase 5 now I'm in no way confirming
what they're going to do I'm simply
using logic Marvel Studios revealed all
of phase 4 at San Diego comic-con then
not too far after at Disney's d23 event
they revealed three new projects now
we're unsure whether or not these are
going to fall into Phase four or phase
five but the fact of the matter is they
did reveal new projects after phase four
was already released and Marvel booked
an insane amount of time to talk about
their future at CinemaCon and Kevin
Feige has already said that they have
phase 5 done they know what the next
five years look like and Kevin Feige
actually said they almost revealed phase
5 at San Diego comic-con they just
thought that there was already nothing
phase four to reveal that there wasn't
enough time well they certainly booked
enough time at CinemaCon to reveal phase
5 even if they talked about all of their
other phase 4 projects that are already
in development there's still enough time
to reveal phase 5 if anything we might
not get a full slate reveal but we could
get a reveal of some projects they have
coming up just like they did at Disney's
d23 event where they announce she-hulk
Miss Marvel and Moon Knight again I'm
not confirming anything but it does seem
very likely that we'll get some type of
phase 5 information at CinemaCon
but at the very least they're going to
be showing some footage from phase 4
which means we will know a lot about
what is shown shortly after which will
definitely be awesome as well
so big things come in from Marvel
whether that's footage or new projects
announced CinemaCon is from March 30th
to April 2nd so not too far away let me
know what you would like to get from
CinemaCon and the comments down below
would you like to get new information
about scenes from one division falcon in
the Winter Soldier and of course Black
Widow and the in Turtles or would you
like to hear more about phase 5 let me
know down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof